>>> WELCOME TO WEEK SIX,
EVERYONE.
AND A HAPPY NFL SUNDAY.
THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU JUST TAPPED INTO THE BETTING
SQUAD RIDE LIVE IN THE BLEACHER
REPORT APP BY DRAFTKINGS.
MY NAME IS CONNOR ROGERS,
ALONGSIDE THE MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
AS ALWAYS YOU WANT TO GET HIS ON
SIDE, GREG IVORY.
GREG, GIVE ME A HOODIE COUNT.
>> JUST TAKE THE OVER.
IN FACT, I'M GIVING AWAY ONE
RIGHT NOW.
SHOUT-OUT TO BAHWET SAYS KAREEM
HUNT TWO TOUCHDOWNS PLUS 450.
I LIKE THAT.
>> I LIKE THAT.
I LIKE THAT A LOT.
BRINGING IT EARLY ON FRIDAY.
WE ASKED YOU ON SOCIAL AND THE
APP TO DROP YOUR LOCKS OF WHO IS
SCORING A TOUCHDOWN AS WE ALWAYS
DO.
HERE ARE THE MOST POPULAR PICKS
THAT YOU SENT US.
NO SURPRISE KENG ING HENRY AT T
TOP.
TRAVIS KELCE RIGHT BEHIND HIM.
EZEKIEL ELLIOTT, LAMAR JACKSON
WITH THE RUSHING TOUCHDOWNS.
WE KNOW WHAT HE DID LAST WEEK,
THE MVP PERFORMANCE FROM THE
MVP.
AARON JONES, DJ MOORE.
PRETTY LOADED BOARD HERE.
REALLY EXCITING WEEK AHEAD.
GET THINGS GOING, THOUGH.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT LAST WEEK'S
LEGEND VIDEOS YOU SENT US THAT
DIDN'T MAKE THE SHOW.
>> ANY TIME A TOUCHDOWN IS
SCORED, LOOK AT THE CLOCK.
>> ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN PICKS
RIGHT HERE AND THE STING RAY
PICK RIGHT HERE.
>> DOING A LITTLE WALK.
WE WILL CHOOSE THEIR TOUCHDOWN.
>> GARY TERRY HOURS.
>> DAVANTE ADAMS ANY TIME SCORE.
>> THERE IT IS.
LOCK IT IN.
>> GOT A BAGEL.
WHAT THE -- WHY IS THAT ON MY
BAGEL?
>> ALL RIGHT, GREG.
TELL THE PEOPLE WHAT ARE WE
GIVING AWAY TODAY?
>> I'M NOT ONLY GIVING OUT
HOODIES, EVERYBODY.
I'M NOT ONLY GIVING OUT HOODIES.
I'M ALSO GIVING AWAY TWO, NOT
ONE BUT TWO NFL JERSEY GIFT
CARDS.
ONE GOES TO THE WINNING LOCK
LEGEND AND THE OTHER GOES TO A
LUCKY CONGR
Y COMMENTER L.
IF YOU NEED A JERSEY, YOU NEED A
HOODIE, I NEED GIFs.
I NEED EMOJIS.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY, CONNOR,
MOST IMPORTANTLY, I NEED WINNERS
ONLY, PLEASE.
FILL THOSE COMMENTS UP BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT I NEED.
I NEED WINNERS.
THAT'S WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR.
>> AS ALWAYS, WE HAVE FOUR
LEGENDARY PICKS TO SHOW YOU.
LOOKING FOR THOSE WINNERS.
THE LAST ONE STANDING WILL BE
OUR WEEK SIX SQUAD RIDE LEADER.
AND THEY GET THE BOOST FROM
DRAFT KINGS.
SO LET'S GET RIGHT INTO IT.
OUR FIRST PICK COMES FROM A
FAMILIAR FACE IN W. TRAMMELL.
TELL US WHO IS SCORING THE
TOUCHDOWN TODAY?
>> WE GOT THE ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN
PLINKO BOARD.
LET'S SEE WHAT WE GET.
AARON JONES.
LOCK IT IN.
>> ALL RIGHT.
AARON JONES COMING IN AT THAT
PLUS MONEY.
PRETTY NICE.
WE GOT OUR FIRST DECISION OF THE
DAY ON TAP.
HERE'S OUR SECOND PITCH FROM P.
McQUAID 18.
>> THE SQUAD RIDE, WE ARE
BETTING.
I THINK YOU GOT ONE.
GOT EZEKIEL ELLIOTT ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN SCORE.
LOCK IT IN.
>> REELING IN LOCKS.
I LIKE IT.
YOU HEARD FROM OUR FIRST TWO
LEGENDS.
GREG, WHO ARE YOU RIDING WITH
HERE?
>> FIRST I GOT TO TALK TO THE
PEOPLE.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, GET INTO THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WE SHOULD
RIDE WITH THE PLINKO LEGEND OR
THE FISHING LEGEND.
CONNOR, THE PLINKO LEGEND, BOTH
VIDEOS WAS IMPRESSIVE.
BOTH VIDEOS TOOK CREATIVITY.
BUT I SEE AARON JONES OVER THERE
PLUS MONEY.
I KNOW WHAT WE COULD DO HERE TO
ADD TO THAT.
AND AARON JONES, HE HASN'T
SCORED THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS,
BUT HE'S DUE.
HE IS DUE.
WE KNOW THAT THEY LIKE TO RUN
THE BALL IN GREEN BAY TO GO
ALONG WITH AARON RODGERS.
SO THAT'S A LITTLE ENTICING TO
ME.
WHAT ABOUT YOU?
>> I LOVE THE PLUS MONEY.
LET'S JUICE IT UP MORE.
YOU GUESSED IT.
AARON JONES TRYING TO FIND HIS
WAY BACK IN THERE.
IT JUST MEANS HE'S DUE.
IT IS NOT A DRAFT.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT AARON JONES
HERE.
OF COURSE ZEKE HAS BEEN OLD
RELIABLE FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS.
THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
BUT I LIKE THE ODDS BETTER ON
THE AARON JONES SIDE.
ALL RIGHT, GREG.
LET'S LET THE PEOPLE PICK THIS
ONE.
WHAT DO YOU SAY FOR ROUND ONE?
>> YES, SIR, CONNOR.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS.
TODAY I HAVE THE HANDY DANDY I
HAD.
FOR PEOPLE NEW TO THE SHOW, THIS
IS HOW YOU GET YOUR HOODIES, AND
THIS IS HOW YOUR GET YOUR
JERSEYS.
I'M IN HERE, CONNOR, AND I SEE
C. BERG WHO SAYS PLINKO LEGEND
FOR SURE.
SHOUTS OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
CONNOR, THE COMMENTS ARE
JUMPING.
I SEE CHRIS SAYS ZEKE TO THE END
ZONE.
ZEKE TO THE END ZONE.
THEY'RE BACK AND FORTH.
NEXT ONE I CHOOSE, WE'RE JUST
GOING TO ROCK WITH IT, CONNOR.
WE'RE JUST GOING TO ROCK WITH
IT.
I SEE RAIDER909.
RAIDER909 SAYS AARON JONES WITH
THE AARON RODGERS EMOJI.
THERE IT IS.
NOT EMOJI BUT A GIF.
SO IT APPEARS, CONNOR, IT
APPEARS THE PLINKO LEGEND, AARON
JONES AND OUR BOY W. TRAMMELL IS
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT ROUND.
THAT'S RIGHT.
TRAMMELL MOVING ON TO ROUND TWO.
BUT WE STILL HAVE TWO
CHALLENGERS REMAINING.
LET'S MOVE THINGS OVER TO ROUND
TWO.
AND OUR NEXT PITCH COMES FROM
KYLE GRIMES 22.
KYLE, LET'S SEE WHAT YOU GOT IN
STORE FOR US FOR WEEK SIX.
>> ALL RIGHT.
ANY TIME TOUCHDOWNS SPEAK, HERE
ARE OUR CHOICES.
COOPER KUPP, ROBINSON, AUSTIN
EKELER.
I'M GOING TO THROW THEM UP.
CATCH THEM IN THE BOOK.
SEE WHAT WE GOT FOR THIS WEEK.
HERE WE GO.
COOPER KUPP.
>> THE ONE TAKE WONDER, THE
MAGIC LEGEND.
YOU HEARD FROM HIM.
DRAKE, WHO ARE YOU RIDING WITH
HERE?
WE GOT PLINKO.
WE GOT THE MAGIC LEGEND.
COOPER KUPP, AARON JONES, MAN.
WHO ARE YOU THINKING HERE?
>> IT'S TOUGH.
THIS ONE IS TOUGH, CONNOR.
I'M NOT GOING TO LIE.
BUT THAT'S WHY WE GOT THE
PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHY I TALK TO THEM AND
THAT'S WHY I'M GOING TO TELL
THEM TO GET INTO THE COMMENTS
AND TELL ME WHO WE SHOULD RIDE
WITH.
COME ON, GUYS.
SHOULD WE GO WITH THE PLINKO
LEGEND IN AARON JONES OR THE
MAGIC LEGEND IN COOPER KUPP.
I'LL BE HONEST, CONNOR.
I WASN'T IMPRESSED BY THE MAGIC.
I WAS NOT IMPRESSED BY THE MAGIC
IN THIS VIDEO.
BUT I AM IMPRESSED BY THE PICK.
COOPER KUPP HAS BEEN BALLING
THIS YEAR, AND HE'S TAKING ON
THAT NEW YORK GIANTS SECONDARY.
MATTHEW STAFFORD JUST LOVES TO
FIND THEM.
BUT, CONNOR, THAT PLUS MONEY
OVER THERE, IT'S JUST -- IT'S
JUST SINGING TO ME.
IT'S SINGING TO ME.
WHAT ABOUT YOU?
>> HOW ABOUT THIS, GREG?
HOW ABOUT WE GET COOPER KUPP TO
B PLUS MONEY.
THAT SHOULD BE OUR OBJECTIVE
HERE.
HE HAS BEEN TARGETED 56 TIMES IN
FIVE GAMES.
THEY JUST THROW THIS GUY THE
BALL NONSTOP, SO IF WE COULD GET
THIS TO PLUS MONEY, I LOVE
COOPER KUPP AGAINST A GIANTS
TEAM.
A TOUGH YEAR, THEY'RE BANGED UP
AND THE DEFENSE HASN'T BEEN AS
GOOD AS IT WAS LAST YEAR IN THE
PASS RUSH.
I DON'T REALLY GET TO DECIDE.
I'M TRYING TO SUEDE THE PEOPLE
TOWARDS COOPER KUPP.
LET'S LET THE PEOPLE DECIDE
ROUND TWO.
>> CONNOR, YOU MADE A GREAT
POINT.
I MEAN, WE HERE ON "THE SQUAD
RIDE" SHOW CAN ONLY BOOST THIS
UP.
WE CAN ONLY DO IT HERE.
WE COULD BOOST COOPER KUPP UP
FOR SOME PLUS MONEY.
WHY NOT?
LET ME GET INTO THESE COMMENTS,
THOUGH.
LET ME SEE WHAT THESE PEOPLE ARE
SAYING.
I GOT JMAN321 SAYING KUPP IS A
LOCK AND IS AMAZING THIS YEAR.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU JMAN321.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
SAYS I THINK AARON JONES ALL THE
WAY.
HE'S GOING TO POP UP WITH -- I
MEAN, I ALSO THINK THAT, TOO.
IT WASN'T SUCH A BAD SPORTS
PICK.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
CONNOR, I GOT ONE MORE.
ONE MORE.
I SEE WD13 SAYS COOPER KUPP.
ROCKING WITH YOU, CONNOR.
YOU ARE ALSO WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
BUT IT APPEARS, CONNOR, IT
APPEARS, I CALLED IT, THE MAGIC
LEGEND, KYLE GRIMES S22 AND
COOPER KUPP IS MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT ROUND.
>> MAN, LOVE THE COOPER KUPP
THING.
LET'S HOPE HE CAN SURVIVE THIS
FINAL ROUND.
KYLE GRIMES MOVING ONGOING FOR
SQUAD RIDE LEADER, GOING FOR
THAT NFL JERSEY.
ALL RIGHT.
WINNER OF THIS ROUND TAKES ALL.
YOU KNOW THE DEAL RIGHT NOW.
NEXT UP IS L2-32.
SEE YOUR PICK.
♪
>> THE WITCH LEGEND GOING WITH
AUSTIN EKELER.
I'M OFFICIALLY TERRIFIED FOR ALL
OF US BUT LOVE THE CREATIVITY
BASED AROUND HALLOWEEN, WHICH IS
RAPIDLY APPROACHING.
ALL RIGHT, GREG.
WE GOT THE FINAL ROUND HERE.
YOU GOT TO RIDE WITH SOMEBODY TO
FINISH THIS OFF.
AUSTIN EKELER AND THE WITCH
LEGEND FOR THE MAGIC LEGEND WITH
OUR BOY COOPER KUPP.
>> CONNOR, I'M OVER HERE TRYING
TO CATCH MY BREATH.
I DON'T KNOW.
THAT WAS SPOOKY.
I KNOW HALLOWEEN IS AROUND THE
CORNER.
LET ME TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME
WHO WE SHOULD RIDE WITH.
SHOULD WE RIDE WITH THE WITCH
LEGEND IN AUSTIN EKELER OR
SHOULD WE RIDE WITH COOPER KUPP,
MY BOY CONNOR?
HE DOES CONVINCE EVERYBODY TO
ROCK WITH IT.
COOPER KUPP, THE MAGIC LEGEND.
I DON'T KNOW, CONNOR.
I DO KNOW AUSTIN EKELER HAS BEEN
BALLING THIS YEAR.
BALLING THIS YEAR, BUT HE'S
FACING BALTIMORE, THAT DEFENSE
IN BALTIMORE.
YOU KNOW, THEY TURN UP IN
BALTI
BALTIMORE.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THEY WANT TO
LEAN THAT WAY.
I THINK THEY WILL ROCK WITH YOU.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE?
ARE YOU STILL LEANING COOPER
KUPP OR ARE YOU GOING TO TAP IN
AUSTIN EKELER?
>> I'M FACING EKELER IN FANTASY
THIS WEEK.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE WHOLE
WITCH THING.
HE MIGHT BE UNDER A SPELL RIGHT
NOW.
I DON'T GET TO DECIDE THE FINAL.
I SPOKE MY CONVINCING ARGUMENT
FOR THE PEOPLE, GREG.
ARE THEY LISTENING?
ARE THEY WITH US FOR COOPER KUPP
AS OUR BOOSTER?
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
LITERALLY, THAT'S ALL I SEE,
CONNOR.
THAT'S ALL I SEE IS COOPER KUPP
IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
I GOT DBRUNHC COOP COOP
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I'VE GOT C. BIRD.
C. BIRD IS BACK.
ROCKING WITH EKELER, IN FACT.
ROCKING WITH EKELER.
HOLD ON.
I SEE -- I SEE MORE COOPER KUPP
LOVE.
I SEE MORE COOPER KUPP -- HOLD
ON.
HERE WE GO.
MAX IS CALLING IT.
HE SAYS COOPER KUPP FOR THE WIN.
COOPER KUPP FOR THE WIN.
SO SHOUT-OUT TO THE MAGIC
LEGEND.
SHOUT-OUT TO COOPER KUPP AND
SHOUT-OUT TO KYLE GRIMES 22.
THAT'S "THE SQUAD RIDE."
LET ME SHOW YOU GUYS SOME MAGIC.
YOU GUYS SEEN COOPER KUPP MINUS
140.
LET ME SHOW YOU SOMETHING THAT
US HERE ONLY ON SQUAD RIDE CAN
DO.
THERE IT IS.
THAT'S THE MAGIC.
PLUS 100.
THANKS TO OUR FRIENDS AT DRAFT
KINGS, THEY BOOSTED THAT FROM
MINUS 140 TO PLUS 100 FOR US.
CHECK THE SOCIAL FOR A LINK.
SEND US YOUR SCREEN SHOTS OF
YOUR BETS.
SEND US YOUR VIDEOS AND YOUR
CELEBRATIONS.
BUT WE WANT WINNERS, AND WINNERS
ONLY, PLEASE.
DON'T FORGET THAT.
>> WE GOT TO PLUS MONEY, GREG.
WE GOT IT TO PLUS MONEY.
WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
COOPER KUPP HOPEFULLY GOING TO
BE A WINNER FOR EVERYBODY
WATCHING THIS SHOW AND THEN TAPS
IN AND RIDES WITH THE SQUAD.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE NOT DONE YET.
GOT MORE LOCKS.
GREG HAS MORE HOODIES AND ONE
MORE JERSEY TO GIVE AWAY.
IT WILL NOT JUST BE KYLE GRIMES
HANGING OUT WITH THAT.
YOU ALREADY KNOW THE DEAL.
WE ASKED YOU THIS WEEK WHO YOU
BET $100 ON TO SCORE MULTIPLE
TOUCHDOWNS IN WEEK SIX.
THIS IS WHAT WE LOVE TO DO.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THOSE BIG TIME
ODDS.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOU THINK.
GREG, LET'S GET INTO IT.
>> YEAH.
I NEED YOU GUYS TO GET INTO THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHICH OF
THESE IS THE BETTER TAKE.
I'M GIVING AWAY A HOODIE TO
WHOEVER YOU CHOOSE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE FIRST
COMMENT FROM THE SPORTS BLOGGER.
SPORTS BLOGGER SAYS LAMAR
JACKSON GRABBING TWO RUSHING
TOUCHDOWNS.
I DO NOT DISLIKE THIS ONE.
THIS ONE IS VERY, VERY, VERY
DOABLE.
CONNOR, WHAT'S YOUR TAKE.
>> I LOVE IT.
HE'S ALREADY DONE IT ONCE THIS
YEAR, RIGHT?
HE DID IT AGAINST THE CHIEFS IN
WEEK TWO IN A WIN, RIGHT?
WE KNOW IN GAMES THAT ARE
SHOOT-OUTS, WHICH THIS GAME IS
GOING TO BE WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHO
THEY'RE PLAYING ACROSS THE WAY
WITH JUSTIN HERBERT AND HE HAD
TO DO THIS AGAINST PATRICK
MAHOMES.
LAMAR PUTS THE TEAM ON HIS BACK.
HE DOES NOT HAVE A GREAT OFFENSE
AROUND HIM.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS, LAMAR WILL
LOOK TO RUN AND GET INTO THE END
ZONE.
SO THE ODDS HERE ARE GOOD.
IT IS A BOLD BET.
THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
I THINK I'M RIDING WITH HIM,
GREG.
WHAT ELSE DO WE GOT IN STORE?
>> I LIKE THIS ONE A LOT.
I'M NOT EVEN GOING TO LIE.
BUT THE NEXT COMMENT, THE NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM Z. McDOWELL
88.
AND HE SAYS, HENRY IS ALWAYS A
GOOD BET TO SCORE TWO
TOUCHDOWNS.
I THINK ZEKE IS GOING TO HAVE
TWO HIMSELF.
BUT IT MIGHT BE ONE RUSHING AND
ONE RECEIVING LIKE LAST WEEK.
ZEKE, YEAH, HE DID HAVE A GOOD
WEEK LAST WEEK, CONNOR.
DO YOU LIKE THIS TAKE.
DO YOU THINK ZEKE IS GETTING
BACK INTO THE END ZONE FOR TWO
TOUCHDOWNS.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S CRAZY.
HE'S DONE IT EVERY SINGLE WEEK
BESIDES WEEK ONE I'M PRETTY SURE
AT THIS POINT WHEN YOU FACTOR IN
THE RECEIVING THREAT AS WELL IN
AN OFFENSE THAT'S SO LOADED.
MY ONLY QUESTION HERE, GREG, AND
WHY YOU MIGHT LEAN LAMAR BESIDES
HOW PROMISING THE ODDS ARE AS
WELL IS THIS IS A DALLAS OFFENSE
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO SPREAD THE
BALL AROUND.
THEY HAVE A PRETTY TOUGH
OPPONENT.
WE KNOW WHAT AMARI HAS DONE.
WE KNOW WHAT CEEDEE HAS DONE.
DAK CAN RUN IN THE RED ZONE WHEN
HE NEEDS TO.
ARE WE FINALLY DUE FOR A WEEK
WHEN ZEKE TAKES A STEP BACK AND
CATCHES HIS BREATH A LITTLE BIT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> YEAH.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF OPTIONS OUT
THERE IN DALLAS.
AND YOU HAVE A GREAT POINT.
WITH A LOT OF OPTIONS, YOU KNOW,
THAT MAY LIMIT ZEKE'S CHANCES OF
SCORING, TOO.
MIGHT GET IN THERE ONCE, BUT
TWO.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DO LIKE THE LAMAR TAKE,
THOUGH, BECAUSE THAT TEAM IS --
WHEN HE GOES, THEY GO.
SO I LIKE THAT TAKE.
LET ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS.
LET ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS
BECAUSE I HAVE TO SEE WHO THE
PEOPLE SAYS THAT WE SHOULD RIDE
WITH.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS, AND I SEE
SOMEBODY STILL TALKING ABOUT
COOPER BALL.
BALL IS LIFE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
COOPER KUPP IS THE SQUAD RIDE,
AND THAT'S WHO WE ARE RUNNING
WITH TODAY.
MAX WELL IS BACK INTO THE
COMMENTS.
HE'S SAYING LAMAR JACKSON.
LAMAR JACKSON, SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
JOE YAN IS ALSO IN THE COMMENTS,
AND HE IS ALSO SAYING LAMAR, EAT
BABY.
SO IT'S APPARENT.
THE PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN.
I'M GOING TO GIVE IT TO THE
SPORTS BLOGGER.
I'M GIVING IT TO THE SPORTS
BLOGGER.
HE'S THE WINNER OF THE COMMENT
CONTEST.
THE SPORTS BLOGGER IS GETTING A
HOODIE.
>> LOVE THE COMMENTS THIS WEEK.
NOW IT IS OUR TURN TO GIVE OUR
CRAZY TAKES.
IT IS BOLDEST BETS TIME.
WE HAVE HAD A LOT OF FUN WITH
THIS.
SOME WEEKS WE GET CRAZY.
SOME WEEKS WE SCALE BACK.
I THINK WE WILL THROW THOSE DIG
TIME DARTS AGAIN.
TELL THE PEOPLE WHAT WE NEED
FROM THEM BEFORE WE CLOSE THIS
THING OUT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME
WHETHER YOU ARE RIDING WITH ME
OR YOU ARE RIDING WITH MY BOY
CONNOR.
MY BOY CONNOR HAS A COUPLE OF
THESE.
SO, CONNOR, TELL THE PEOPLE WHAT
YOU GOT THIS WEEK?
>> I'M EXCITED ABOUT THIS ONE.
AFTER COOLING OFF LAST WEEK, I
FEEL LIKE I GOT TO COMEBACK.
I'M GOING Ja'MARR CHASE NOT ONE
BUT TWO TOUCHDOWNS AGAINST THE
LIONS.
THERE WAS A LOT OF TALK OF IF
THE BENGALS SHOULD TAKE CHASE OR
GO OFFENSIVE LINE.
I THINK CHASE HAS NOTHING TO
PROVE.
HE'S BEEN UNGUARDABLE THIS YEAR.
HE'S GOING TO BRING IT ANYWAY
THIS WEEK.
I THINK HE GETS IN THE END ZONE
NOT ONCE BUT TWICE AGAINST A
WEAK LIONS DEFENSE.
AND PLUS 600, GREG, LET'S MAKE
SOME MONEY TODAY.
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING?
>> I'M ROOTING FOR YOU.
HE'S ON MY FANTASY TEAM.
I NEED THOSE TWO TUBS, BABY.
BUT I WANT TO TAKE IT TO THE MVP
RACE, CONNOR.
I WANT TO TAKE IT TO THE MVP
RACE.
LAMAR JACKSON, JUSTIN HERBERT,
THEY'RE PLAYING EACH OTHER.
BUT I WANT THEM TO COMBINE FOR
OVER 600 PASSING YARDS.
YOU GUYS GO OUT THERE COMBINED
FOR OVER 600 PASSING YARDS.
YOU JUST MENTIONED THIS MIGHT BE
A HIGH SCORING GAME.
SO YOU GO OUT THERE AND THROW
THAT THING AROUND FOR A LITTLE
BIT.
GIVE ME THAT PLUS 380.
DRAFT KING ALREADY BOOSTED IT
FOR US.
SO GO SLING THE ROCK A LITTLE
BIT, GUYS, AND LET'S MAKE SOME
MONEY.
>> I LIKE THAT CALL.
IT'S GOING TO BE A SHOOT-OUT.
WE HAVE SEEN HERBERT HAVE NO
PROBLEM DOING THIS.
IF YOU CAN GET 330 OUT OF
HERBERT, 270 OUT OF LAMAR,
THAT'S AN EXCITING ONE.
THE ODDS ARE HUGE.
LET'S HAVE SOME FUN.
LET'S MAKE SOME MONEY.
BUT WE NEED TO KNOW WHO ARE THE
PEOPLE RIDING WITH?
ARE THEY GOING WITH YOU WITH A
LAMAR JACKSON HERBERT SPECIAL?
I THINK YOU STILL HAVE ONE MORE
NFL JERSEY TO GIVE AWAY.
>> YES, SIR.
I'M GOING TO GIVE AWAY THE
JERSEY FIRST, CONNOR.
JERSEY FIRST.
AND GUESS WHAT?
I'M GIVING AWAY TO REDSOXIN5.
SAYS Ja'MARR CHASE IS A LOCK.
>> A LOCK!
LET'S GO.
>> YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
YOUR CHOICE.
NOW I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES,
CONNOR.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS GIVING AWAY
A HOODIE.
I'VE GOT JJ SNELL.
HE SAID THAT'S FIRE.
SHOUTS OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT BALLISLIFE.
I THINK THEY GOT A HOODIE
EARLIER, BUT, YOU KNOW, WHEN WE
SHOW LOVE TO PEOPLE WHO SHOW
LOVE TO US, THEY SAID COOPER
KUPP.
>> SQUAD RIDE.
>> YEAH.
THEY'RE GIVING US GOOD VIBES.
I ALREADY GAVE YOU A HOODIE, BUT
IF I -- YEAH, HOODIE, HOODIE.
GIVE THEM A HOODIE.
I GOT ONE MORE.
ONE MORE.
LANDONFOS18 SAYS ROCK IING WITH
BOTH.
SHOUT-OUT TO LANDON.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH IT.
CONNOR, LET'S TAKE THIS THING
HOME.
>> GREG, I'M FEELING ODDLY
OPTIMISTIC THAT THIS IS THE WEEK
ALL THE LONG SHOTS HIT.
ALL THE COMMENTS CONTESTS, THE
BOLDEST BETS.
GOOD LUCK WITH YOUR WAGERS,
EVERYONE.
WE WILL DM YOU WITHIN 24 HOURS.
THANKS TO EVERYONE THAT
COMMENTED.
YOU GOT TO COMMENT IF YOU WANT
TO WIN, AND YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN
BRINGING IT EVERY SINGLE WEEK.
GREG HAS BEEN -- WE HAVE BEEN
HAVING FUN WITH THAT.
OUR LEGENDS, THE LOCK LEGENDS.
OF COURSE L232.
ENJOY YOUR NFL SUNDAY.
>> WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
CONNOR, BEFORE WE GET OUT OF
HERE, I HAVE TO GIVE OUT MORE
HOODIES.
I GOT RICH BAR TELL WHO SAYS,
HE'S ON MY FANTASY TEAM.
SO RICH BARTEL, YOU ARE TALKING
AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
THAT'S PROBABLY A LOT OF PLUS
MONEY.
HE'S ROCKING WITH Ja'MARR CHASE.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
THAT'S IT, CONNOR.
THAT'S IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE DONE HERE.
ALONGSIDE GREG IVORY.
MY NAME IS CONNOR ROGERS.
SEE YOU NEXT WEEK.
SAME TIME.
SAME PLACE.